[Musique]
pour se rendre au travail existe
désormais le métropolite monsieur
guimard a été invité à enjoliver les
bouches du réseau parisien de chemin de
fer souterrain
un journaliste du thym écrit c'est
hiéroglyphes désordonnée jette dans un
émoi excusable les petits enfants à qui
l'on apprend à leurs lettres dans un
alphabet français et il cause la stupeur
des étrangers en promenade dans paris
des lampadaires étrange sorte de bras
dressé sur des queues de fonte tenons
entre leurs crochets des fruits de verre
en forme de berlingots admis sucer
l'arrêt dans la rue et la station de
métro ressemble à un salon bourgeois
[Musique]
ce patient dauphine au bout de l'avenue
du poids
[Musique]
non
mon
[Musique]
don
on
e
où
[Musique]
on
à
e
[Musique]
où
nous
[Musique]
e
on
[Musique]
ben
tout le monde descend aux enfers et
demeure étonné des normes cylindre de
métal ont été enfoncés dans le sol de
paris station cité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
à
[Musique]
le
bon
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lever les yeux dans le métro vous y
verrez la main du chaudronnier et du
serrurier les matériaux modernes faire
ou fonte vert et briscous faïence
n'exclut jamais un travail d'artisan
station barbès rochechouart
il
[Musique]
c'est colossal enfilade de jean camille
formigé ne s'inscrive t'elle pas dans la
suite de l'alignement des piliers de
notre dame ou de la colonnade du louvre
dans le faire comme sculptée dans de la
pierre les moyens de transports font
aller et venir les abeilles de la ruche
symbole du métro qui véhiculent des
millions de travailleurs chaque jour
[Musique]
ces colonnes de fer qui ne sont pas en
marbre soutiennent un monde le monde du
progrès et du travail
[Musique]